MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we talk
about the famous twin paradox.
It's probably the most famous
paradox in special relativity.
I want to get to
the bottom of this,
and understand
really where there
is a conflicting or
contradictory statement
in this story.
Let me just first say that
this is personal to me.
I do have a twin
brother, and you
can see three pictures of
myself and my twin brother here.
We were very little on our
first day of school in Germany.
You get a little
box of candy when
you go to schools to make it
more attractive to actually
learn and study.
And then a picture,
which is probably already
about 10 years old.
What you can take away
from here is clearly
moving clocks are slow.
It turns out that
my twin brother
lives in the very same
village in Germany
where I grew up,
where we both grew up,
while I traveled the world
constantly and constantly
on the road between
France and Geneva
and Switzerland and
the United States.
And again, I think there
is no dispute here.
It can be seen from this picture
that your professor looks
much younger.
I even have a more
recent picture.
This is two years ago.
The German Kris Kringle Market,
where I asked my brother
to take this picture for
this class, for 8.20.
And again, I think the answer
to the question is clear.
Professor Klute has aged less.
All right.
On a more serious
note, we're going
to quantitatively understand
and analyze the situation.
And we use Bob and Alice again.
In this situation,
here Bob stays local.
Alice has a spacecraft, and she
moves with the velocity of 0.6,
six times the speed of light,
a gamma factor of 1.25.
The travel takes her
to a distant star,
which is in this example
It's three light years away
from Bob, measured by Bob.
The journey takes her, on
Bob's clock, five years,
and the return takes
another five years.
She doesn't spend much time.
She wants to go home
as quickly as possible.
If you analyze this,
from Alice's perspective,
we see that for Alice, the
journey takes four years,
and the distance traveled
for her in a spacecraft is 0.
From Bob's perspective, the
journey, as seen by Alice,
is only 3.2 years long.
And so we find that
there's already a conflict.
If you add the times together,
both ways, the inbound
and the outbound ways, 6.4
years is not equal to 10 years.
So there's already a
contradictory statement
in this story.
But the key to the
understanding of this problem
is that Alice, in
order to return,
has to change reference points.
And there, we do have to
resynchronize the clocks,
if you want, or add a
specific extra factor.
And we'll go back
to this when we
look at space and [INAUDIBLE].
So the time, as seen
by Bob, is 3.2 years
for the outbound journey,
and then 3.6 years
in order to resynchronize
the clocks on the return,
on the turning around.
And then 3.2 years on the
return, which makes 10 years.
And so that observation
of Bob, of Alice,
is in agreement with
Bob's own clock.
All right.
So we saved the day here.
Let's look at
space-time diagrams.
The outbound journey
is shown here.
You see I've got it--
in addition to Bob's
reference frame,
I've plotted Alice's reference,
and it makes it easier
to understand what's going on.
So we see in Alice's
reference frame,
the journey takes four years.
If you then go back to the
position in which Bob is,
3.2 years have passed.
So this is iffy.
At the time when Alice
arrives we go back
to the position of Bob,
3.2 years have passed.
We then turn around and
ask the very same question.
At that time-- it's
still four years--
we go back the other
direction now to Bob,
we are already
much further ahead,
3.2 years plus 3.6 years.
And then the journey continues,
and we add another 3.2 years
to the journey.
When Alice and
Bob reunite, Alice
aged by eight years, 2 times
4, and Bob aged by 10 years.
So the question now is,
there may be a paradox here.
Is it possible that we
missed somehow that by--
and try to understand why this
is a probably not symmetric.
Why can I not just use
the other reference frame,
and just declare that
Alice stayed stationary
in her spacecraft while
Bob moved away with Earth
and then came back?
Why are those two
things not consistent?
The answer is that
it's not Bob who
has to change reference
frame, but Alice.
It's Alice who has to do this.
There is where the asymmetry is.
You can argue if you want that,
in order for Alice to do that,
she actually has to accelerate.
But we don't have any
sort of discussion
of how the acceleration
actually went about.
It's really the change
in reference frame
which is crucial
in this discussion,
and causes the asymmetry
between Bob and Alice.